for breaking news now and in the last
few moments the office
for national statistics has published
gdp figures
for the fourth quarter of last year
let's uh speak now to our economics and
data editor
ed conway uh what can you tell us ed
well jillian these numbers have
literally just come out so at the moment
i just have the
the overall figure which is a 1.1 uh
sorry one percent growth
uh in the final quarter of last year now
that's actually a little bit better
than expected uh bear in mind that a lot
of people thought because of that second
lockdown
in much of the country during that
period that you might have seen
a contraction which would in turn
potentially lead to a double-dip
recession well
that hasn't happened it's one percent
growth
and when you look at the total year as a
whole
i think that we're talking about around
9.9 so around
10 percent of a fall in gdp
last year i'm going to have to kind of
go back into the spreadsheets and work
out when the last time that was
as bad i think that might be a little
bit
less bad than we saw in the 1920s
i mean a lot of people at the time were
talking about how this was going to be
the worst recession
since uh the 18th century the early
period of the 18th century
in terms of the the total fall over 2020
well now we have those preliminary
numbers
it may not be quite as bad as that but
as i say uh the figures have just
dropped so we're going to have a look at
them over the course
of the next um hour or so we'll also be
talking to the chancellor rishi sunak
about his reaction to those numbers
uh and indeed to the state of the
economy now because in a way i think the
issue with this is
what we're doing right now and obviously
he's in the process of preparing for a
budget
what we're doing right now is looking at
numbers that are quite historic they're
numbers that cover
uh the final three months of last year
and during that period obviously there
was this uh
lockdown in much of the country but it
wasn't as severe as the lockdown that
we're facing
uh around most of the uk at the moment
uh and so the
expectation is the quarter we're in at
the moment so the period we're in right
now i know i suppose the question is
whether he's going to do anything more
like that is he
are there going to be stimulus measures
like eat out to help out uh they're
going to get get the economy going again
uh perhaps you'd have thought he
wouldn't do that
again but as i was saying this course
we're in right now this period we're in
at the moment
almost every economist thinks that we're
going to see a contraction and
some people have talked about double dip
recessions and there is this arbitrary
it's pretty arbitrary
idea that a recession is only when you
have two successive quarters of
contraction well because last quarter
the one we're talking about now
because there was growth then you're not
going to have a technical recession
but for most people when they look at
the numbers what they will conclude is
we're in a period right now of
potential contraction that's not good
news we'll have more from the chancellor
on that later on and more analysis
giving you a sense of just how
bad last year was really in historical
perspective